it's like a symphony of manipulating and
spinning and flipping the cards in your
hands
[Music]
it's like each move inspires the next
and you're not even thinking about it
the cards are dancing
between the hands they're spinning
around they're flipping over they're
doing things you wouldn't even expect
them to be doing
it's just so surprising almost magical
[Music]
for as long as i can remember we've
always done things in tandem together
we both got into magic around the age of
12.
we would go to the library and check out
books by dia vernon guy hollingworth
just seeing the illustrations we're like
wow we can do this with playing cards
when we started practicing cardistry
it wasn't a thing
it has its roots in magic it comes from
card magicians who would use what is
called a card flourish and these were
used to accentuate certain moments in a
magic trick
so we took that and just ran with it
we were the first to embrace it and
really focus on it
and practice it as its own thing and
promote it as its own thing
[Music]
cardistry is very much like
skateboarding you know we practice these
tricks until we have them down perfect
you know we see other tricks and we're
like oh we gotta learn that
you have 52 playing cards and the
possibilities to to maneuver those
around are endless
you can hold a deck of cards in your
hand and it's one solid block now
imagine lifting up another block so now
you have two well what can you do with
those two blocks in your hands well you
can create more blocks and we call those
packets and you can start maneuvering
and spinning and flipping those packets
between your fingers
it's hard like it takes a lot of
dexterity
it's all
practiced it's all rehearsed and when
you're truly a master you can just start
doing things on the fly and you don't
even have to think about it
[Music]
what kids are doing today with cards is
mind-blowing
if you would have told me that when i
was 14 years old i would have been like
that's the coolest thing i had no idea
it could even be this big
the ultimate goal would be to get people
to almost put cardistry first
when they see a deck of playing cards
you know it's no longer for games it's
no longer for gambling it's cardistry
[Music]
you